in this video we're going to take a look
at every color of lightsaber and their
meanings in Star Wars cannon so here are
the top seven lightsaber colors as seen
in the Star Wars films and TV shows
before we talk about the different
lightsaber colors though we need to talk
about the source of their power kyber
crystals kyber crystals are living
organisms that are connected to the
force and they can be found on planets
that have a high natural concentration
of force energy such as Jetta and ilum
kyber crystals are clear and colorless
until they are attuned to a for
sensitive user who must meditate with
the Crystal and Infuse their feelings
and personality into it this process
gives the crystal its color which
reflects the alignment and philosophy of
the user for example blue crystals are
associated with Justice and Truth while
green crystals are linked to wisdom and
peace the color of the crystal also
affects the performance and appearance
of the lightsaber such as its brightness
sound and blade shape kyber crystals are
not only the heart of the lightsaber but
also the heart of the Jedi and the Sith
as they reflect their connection to the
force and their identity kyber crystals
are also used for other purposes such as
powering Starships weapons and T temples
but they're most famously known for
creating the most elegant and iconic
weapon in the Galaxy the lightsaber the
first color we're going to talk about is
blue the most common color among the
Jedi blue lightsabers signify Justice
truth and serenity they are often
wielded by Jedi Guardians who focus on
combat skills and physical abilities
blue lightsabers are also associated
with loyalty and courage as well as a
strong connection to the force some of
the most famous blue lightsaber users
are Obi-Wan Kenobi Anakin Skywalker Luke
Skywalker and Ray Jedi Knights who were
skilled in the Force like the Guardians
could utilize their talent during battle
by using the force to throw objects
intercept projectiles and more Jedi who
were ready to fight on the front line
generally used a blue lightsaber blade
to denote their place as a guardian the
second color is green another popular
choice among the Jedi green lightsabers
represent growth Harmony and nature they
are usually wielded by Jedi Consolers
who specialize in diplomacy healing and
force knowledge green lightsabers are
also linked to wisdom and peace as well
as a deeper understanding of the force
some of the most notable green
lightsabers users are Quon Jinn Yoda
Luke Skywalker Ezra Bridger and Ahsoka
Tano Quon Jin and Yoda both used green
lightsabers and challenged The
Establishment in their study of the
force Luke Skywalker also upgraded to a
green blade after he became a Jedi
master and learned more about the force
in starw Wars Return of the Jedi the
third color is red the signature color
of the Sith and other Dark Side users
red lightsaber symbolize anger strength
and determination they are created by a
process called bleeding where a dark
side user bends a kyber crystal to their
will causing it to crack and bleed
giving it a corrupted and unstable
energy for example kylo Ren's Crystal
was damaged during the bleeding process
which is why his lightsaber has a fiery
and crackling blade red lightsabers are
also indicative of power and domination
as well as a willingness to kill and
destroy some of the most infamous red
lightsaber users are Darth Vader Darth
Maul Darth cidus kylo Ren and balen
skull balen skull is a new character
introduced in the Ahsoka series and he
wields an orange lightsaber which is the
rare variation of red his lightsaber is
said to be a result of a failed bleeding
process where he tried to corrupt a
yellow kyber Crystal but only managed to
change its Hue slightly the fourth color
is yellow a rare and unique color among
the Jedi yellow lightsabers signify
balance protection and service they are
often wielded by Jedi Sentinels who
combine combat skills and force
knowledge with practical skills and
stealth yellow lightsabers are also
associated with Guardianship and
leadership as well as a dedication to
the Jedi order some of the most
prominent yellow lightsaber users are
the Jedi Temple guards Ray and Assange
Ventress Jedi temples were often guarded
by Sentinels who carried yellow
double-bladed lightsabers reay's new
lightsaber blade was also yellow
representing her desire to work closely
with people by using the other skills
she gained in her Mission she was also
tasked with protecting the ideal she had
learned from the Lost Temple of the Jedi
the fifth color is purple a very rare
and special color among the Jedi purple
lightsabers signify nobility royalty and
wisdom they are usually wielded by Jedi
who have a strong connection to both the
light and the dark sides of the forest
and who can balance them without falling
to the dark side purple lightsabers are
also indicative of individuality and
Charisma as well as a Mastery of the
force the most famous purple lightsaber
user is Mace Wu who is one of the most
powerful and respected Jedi Masters of
his time the sixth color is white the
color that's not naturally found in
kyber crystals white lightsabers signify
Purity Clarity and healing they are
created by a process called purification
where a lights side user heals a blood
kyber Crystal restoring its natural
state and removing its color white
lightsabers are also associated with
neutrality and Independence as well as a
Detachment from the Jedi and the Sith
the most well-known white lightsaber
user is ahsokatano who left the Jedi
Order and forged her own path as a force
user she healed the crystals of the
sixth brother a fallen Jedi who had
become an Inquisitor and used them to
create her own white lightsabers the
seventh and final color is black a color
that's exclusive to one lightsaber in
the entire galaxy the dark saber the
dark saber is a unique and ancient
weapon that was created by tar visla the
first Mandalorian Jedi the dark saer
signifies Authority Legacy and honor it
is the symbol of the Mandalorian people
and their culture and it's passed down
from one lader to the next the dark
saber is also associated with conflict
and Challenge and it's often contested
by rival factions and clans the dark
saber features a flat black blade much
shorter than a typical lightsaber housed
in a hilt made from the Mandalorian
metal best car the dark saer is also
unique because of the mental connection
its wielder has to forge with it to
properly wield the blade some of the
most prominent dark saer wielders are
tarva prea Darth Maul Sabine Ren batan
cre and djaren what's your favorite
color of lightsaber drop your answers in
the comments below also don't forget to
subscribe for more Star Wars content and
if you like the video check out the
other one on your screen
too